so the cost of living crisis is clearly
hitting everybody what's going on well
it's all about this inflation and as we
know inflation after a long period of
being comfortably below two percent has
started rising and as time's gone on
it's risen it's now 10 with forecasts
like this one from the bank of England
suggesting it could rise into the mid
teens before maybe hopefully it falls
next year but we don't even know that it
will fall next year it could be up there
in the double digits for many years to
come unless the bank increases interest
rates to bring it under control the
challenge for households in the UK is
it's not only the absolute inflation
number that matters it's the things we
really spend money on which varies by
sector and so things like housing costs
and food and drink the cost of those has
risen even faster and of course
crucially energy
fine that's the big picture but let's
try to put it in context for a typical
household meet Faisal and Sarah nephizon
and Sarah are a couple young couple with
kids they live in the outskirts of
Manchester in a semi-detached house she
ends a little bit more than he does
about 55 000 a year of income he's on
thirty five thousand crucially Faisal
and Sarah have a mortgage it's a bit
higher than an average mortgage about
300 000 pound mortgage and they took
that out when interest rates were low
they have to refinance early next year
let's see the effect that has on them
firstly let's look at where they are
today so right now Faisal and Sarah in
2022 this is a typical monthly budget
for this family they're monthly bill on
energy of course at the start of 2022
before all the inflation hit the energy
bills was about you know a thousand
pounds 1200 pounds a year but look
what's happened to their mortgage costs
over the last period this is before the
mini budget was announced much higher
mortgage costs much higher energy costs
the effect of the mini budget energy
costs right down because of that energy
price cap but look as the bank has
responded with higher interest rates
expected because of the spending that
mortgage costs have increased just as
much as their energy costs have
decreased
they've robbed Peter to pay Paul